there's this other God pharoh Jack and
he if he if you don't pray enough he'll
cast a spell upon you called Brimstone
and basically if you'll get bad luck do
you but do you see what's happening now
now what's happening is you have this
innate disposition to worship God alone
but because you've broke him down into
segments you have these all these demig
gods that you need to be like okay I
need to do this or this God will do this
to me good so I go to the one God with
many attributes rather than one God with
Demi subcategorized individuals who are
doing different jobs you get what I'm
trying to say become this Believers or
monics but those who Excel towards God
it's not based on color what skin color
you are how many you know what you have
ex what money you earn or hierarchy of
how much wealth you have Etc no we
believe every human being has a
potential to get closer to God by his
righteous Deeds not by his color Now by
what hierarchy he is this this is not in
Islam this is Injustice and Allah has
negated Injustice to himself think about
it if someone created Created like like
a website okay let's let's give this
website creat name like suit or
something and he had different like
administrators for the website would you
go straight to or would you go to the
different administrators I will go
straight look the analogy you're given I
will go to the one look I will go to the
one who is the master that if a fly was
to come in front of the idol Brahma
whatever Vish whatever you want to call
and the Fly was to take its food it
can't even protect its food from the fly
just listen to me so now imagine you're
praying but you've got five problems
today Financial somebody upset you
you're going from an illness now you're
thinking oh I need to write down I need
to go to this God for that that God for
this Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support this donation will be a sar for
you because every person that comes a
step closer to Allah through your
donation you will in be reaping the
reward click the link and donate what
you can let's go next caller please
let's push all
together Salam alaykum um hello um
okay I am from India I'm a transgender
Hindu and um I was wondering what your
views are on lgbtq rights and whether
Muslims have a future in India
okay do you mind I just want to know if
you're sincere do you mind if we can see
your face um okay one second it's just
you know we get trolls and stuff like
that trolling and all that stuff we just
want like and you troll that once three
seconds you have three seconds and then
you're off you know just just reminding
you guys but yeah okay so all right I
appreciate so yourself you you are a
trans Hindu yes okay so
and okay all right so okay so um yeah so
what's our views uh are you asking so
you're asking as Not My Views about
Islam yeah yes yes okay so what I would
say is very simple um that in Islam we
believe that anybody that um dresses up
as a man that dressed up as a woman or a
woman that dressed up as a man we
believe the curse of God is on them now
this is obviously a it's a general
ruling however like I said to you before
um that we don't believe we believe that
whatever God has willed uh if Allah has
willed God Almighty has willed that you
are a man you are a man and now can you
would you have Tendencies or you know
what I want to be a woman I feel that
these are things that we are all tested
with yeah there are there are Muslims
who are tested with homosexual
tendencies there are Muslim men who just
can't help but sleep around there are
women who go and sleep around these are
tendencies that we need to control why
because the greater purpose in our life
is to worship God and him alone and and
survive the test of life and when we go
to paradise we will have whatever we
want yeah that is obviously a thing that
is not against what Allah has decreed so
the whole purpose is this what's your
name by the way um my name is
advic alick advic advic yeah so in in
the N show my my dear um brother my
friend is that look we're just here to
be tested we have desires left right
center and we believe even if you're an
be like you know you know trans Etc you
have a relation you should have a
relationship with God God does not hate
you this likes you it's the sin so you
should you can still have a relationship
with God and you said you're a Hindu so
you believe in multiple deities yeah so
my main deities are um Vishnu and this
this unknown one it's called copson um
okay so tell me about V Vishnu who's
Vishnu okay so basically in the um
there's there's like a Hindu Tri
environment um so Vu is one of brahma's
like Sons basically and he represents
like rebirth and all that and I'm he's
like one of like the main ones in my
family he's been passed around through
generations so that's why okay so you
know Brahma so Brahma who's Brahma okay
so you know you have like Allah in Islam
right so Brahma is basically the Creator
in the Hindu religion
okay so does Brahma have an image um not
really he's kind of described you can
there's like but no one really like
knows
wow so so so does Brahma is he is he um
is there statues of him is there Idols
of him yes okay so he does they have
given a form to him yeah yes okay so you
said the other one was Vishnu yeah and
okay what characteristics does he have
that Brahma doesn't have that Brahma
needs him okay so basically um Vishnu is
one of like brahma's Sons Brahma has
like one daughter and two sons and
Brahma doesn't like control like d
anymore he's above that now and so his
sons are in control of it and his
daughter and his sons also have Sons
Sons and they're like forms of the
father in other ways like um this one
copson he's also another m one he's one
of the sons of
Vishnu okay so does Brahma have
daughters um yes he has two sons one
daughter okay so in a nutshell we
believe this is idol worship and we are
giving different attribute it's like
it's like us believing in Allah and
making each attribute Divine so there's
for example making the Angels the Angels
Divine so what we're seeing is this my
my dear brother is that look we believe
that God is one he does not have
partners he has attributes We Believe
Allah has 99 names that we know of he
has attributes that belong to him so his
attribute of all knowing there's not an
all knowing son or an all- knowing go uh
God or all knowing this or he's the all
knowledgeable that doesn't mean there's
a SE separate demig good so what we're
saying is that our fitra f means your
innate disposition is created for what
that we accept that God is one and you
deep down actually believe that that's
why we believe every child is born a
Muslim until their families make them
what they are so to me this concept that
you have of Brahma vishna this person
that person we're seeing worship God
Alone Now if God look God has to be one
if God has more than one partner there
will be chaos would you not accept that
no because I think like copson is very
like influential like keeping the road
in check okay so see so what that means
is this now God has Brahma has who's
what's he called krna cson CS so cson so
what that means is cannot Brahma do that
on his own that he needs caps him well
Brahma is above that now he's he's like
okay if he's if he's if he above that
means that at one moment he was below
that so that's a weakness in God that we
negate so what that means if at one
moment Brahma had these attributes which
is not praiseworthy and he's above that
now that means god at one point had
these traits that doesn't befit him we
say that doesn't befit God because we
don't say he's above that now and now
he's given this job to his son or
daughter do you get what I'm trying to
say it's a blasphemy against God we say
Allah has always been perfect and is
perfect he has always been the all
knowing not at one moment at time he was
not knowledgeable like Jesus like
Christians believe that Jesus Is God and
he chose to be ignorant he didn't know
the season of the Fig or he didn't know
when the hour was we say you cannot
negate these attributes that belong to
the creation to the Creator this is what
we call shik we say God is the all
knowing and has always been the all
knowing he's the all wise and is always
all wise he's the Creator and he's
always been the Creator even though
there was no creation so we say that
those attributes belong to God Alone why
com uh uh divide it into segmentations
and then say oh he was like this before
because you're attributing weakness to
God do you get it you would accept that
can God cannot never be weak right yeah
but think of it there's two there's two
traits okay so there's Heavenly traits
which we call aryion and there is
Earthly traits which is like the gods
that treat us the Earthly traits are
called
Jimmy okay but this is this is again uh
uh uh my dear friend once you talk about
Earthly traits and Heavenly traits again
it falls into this is why I came to
Islam I looked into a bit of Hinduism
before I came to Islam this is one of
the reasons I rejected Hinduism and
Christianity because it's kind of
similar why because it's like Earthly
characteristics Heavenly characteristics
we believe God has one one Essence in
the sense where it doesn't change oh
today God is weak but he will be strong
in heaven on the earth he's weak but in
heaven he's strong we don't believe this
concept we believe God in his true
nature does not have these
characteristics of a human being look
today I can be strong I went to the gym
I benched this I went boxing but
tomorrow I feel ill and I'm weak so what
I'm saying is that that only belongs to
the creation like me I'm weak I can
become stronger but Allah is the most
powerful and always the powerful so do
you see why there's problems in that
aspect because now you've turned God
into like it's like a like a circus do
you get what I'm trying to say yeah but
there's there's like things that you
could do to not become weak in Hinduism
we call being weak Brimstone um and we
it's basically like an effect if you do
if you don't pray
enough yeah okay so so so again like by
the way look it's the thing is here just
just want to touch upon this is that we
are you're saying there are things in
Hinduism that we believe that one can do
to not be weak are you talking about a
human being or good um okay so there's
there's this other God Pharaoh Jack and
he if he if you don't pray enough he'll
cast a spell upon you called Brimstone
I'm trying to explain this in English
terms that's why it's kind of like off
but it's called brimstone and basically
if you'll get bad luck do you but do you
see what's happening now now what's
happening is you have this innate disos
to worship God alone but because you've
broke him down into segments you have
these all these demig gods that you need
to be like okay I need to do this or
this God will do this to me do you see
what you've done like if you think about
in essence you actually
believe you want to believe in the
Oneness of God like we do but what
you've done is now you've got these
multiple gods divided into different
sections of different characteristics
and you're like if I do this I'll be
cursed by that that God is controlled of
that now you are serving multiple
because in my head I'm like okay I know
Allah is the one that can punish me I
don't think of another demigod I just
think Allah has his characteristics he's
the all wise so number one I trust him
in his judgment when something happens
to me in my life and it doesn't make
sense I'm like I trust my God because
he's the all wise good so I go to the
one God with many attributes rather than
one God with Demi subcategorized
individuals who are doing different jobs
you get what I'm trying to say so you
your essence is that you you have the
inclination of believing in one God
you've just have these different
demigods and I'm just saying why don't
you worship God Alone which is Allah W
and then and then you can say you know
what for example if I shouldn't wrong
people because when I want that for
myself and Allah can punish me instead
of thinking oh no there's this other
demigod I need to make sure cuz I don't
want to get cursed by him do you get
what I'm trying to say yeah so there's a
group of people called brahans and they
believe that they're directly playing to
Brahma um it's it's it's this sort of
thing called like babbey does is Islam
basically like babbey does it accept
that no no we don't we don't have this
hierarchy so in Hinduism you have
hierarchy yeah okay we don't have this
we believe everybody in the sight of
Allah is equal and those who get closer
to Allah subhana tala um like as human
beings but those who transgress become
disbelievers or monaf but those who
Excel towards God this not based on
color what skin color you are how many
you know what you have Etc what money
you earn or hierarchy of how much wealth
you have Etc no we believe every human
being has a potential to get closer to
God by his righteous Deeds not by his
color not by what hierarchy he is this
this is not in Islam this is Injustice
and Allah has negated Injustice to
himself why would it be just that
somebody has a hierarchy getting closer
to God or have connection to God why I
have a potential as a person who may
have been far away from God come into
Islam and being better than somebody
who's been a Muslim all of his life it's
based on tawa it's based on your God
Consciousness and being closer to him do
you get what I'm trying to say so this
racism or like hierarchy this is not in
Islam my brother do you believe in
interface
marriage I believe in Interfaith
marriages Islam and as a Muslim man can
marry a Christian chrisan a Jew but we
are not allowed to marry Idol
worshippers neither um a Muslim woman
married allowed to marry Christian Jew
or Idol worshippers but a Muslim man can
marry a Christian and a
Jew sorry why oh what made you say that
in um in India there was a a Muslim boy
dating a Hindu girl recently and the
Hindu girl basically got like like beat
up at the at the store what is yeah it's
horrible who got who got be up the
Muslim boy um no it a Hindu girl oh the
got beat up for marrying a Muslim yeah
well you see this is the issue you know
this is this is like I said to you
before you at end day we don't have this
concept of being beaten up we just say
the marriage is invalid yeah we don't go
and beat the Muslim woman up with the
man we don't believe that yeah but in an
Essence let's come back toed my my
brother why do you not worship God Alone
why don't you worship God is one there's
nothing like him look for example in the
Quran that we
say say Allah is one he's
self-sufficient you know when you talk
about Brahma has this this that
self-sufficient means he needs
Nobody he does not beget nor is he
begotten and there is nothing like him
so why this concept why don't you come
to Islam worship God alone you don't
have to this hierarchy this that Etc you
worship the one true creator which is
deserving of worship and this is the way
we understand Brahman to be as well it's
meaning actual reality is only with God
but but but but but but their attribute
of Brahma is totally different because
they they they believe he was so no I'm
saying originally if you go back to the
origin even if you define Brahman if you
define the word Brahman what it actually
means it's very close to the way okay
it's it's very close but like Brahma for
example if it's let's say Brahma was
let's say the way they explained it
we're like okay that's like what we
believe is Allah yeah but even the name
we don't call Allah Brahma no no we
don't say that yeah but the essence in
itself it is because I know some people
are going to clip this out and be like
oh he's trying to say Brahma is Allah
he's not saying that
yeah it's it's what he's saying is this
that the true concept of Brahma from the
beginning could have been that it's the
worship of the one true God what we're
saying is distorted now so what I'm
saying to you my brother is that why
don't you worship God Alone just him one
think about it like a company do you go
to the CEO for minor request if I want
to be kind I pray to Wholesome soy Jack
if I wanted to be um like calm I pray to
calm Jack if I wanted to be something
you know you don't go to the higher up
for minor but do you see do you see okay
why can't you go to the higher up what's
stopping you why do you have to go to
these different deities you said when I
need this I go to that it's like you got
it's like you got so many different
people you go to for different stuff
we're seeing we have I have a 100
problems and I go to one God you're
seeing I have 100 problems I go to 100
different
gods yeah so so they can help Advocate
you to your needs correctly no no no no
no one second 30 330 million Divas no no
no there is there so many gods like you
going but one second something really
profound one second you are saying that
I need to go to individual and it's like
an expert in that field yes is that what
you're saying yeah I'm seeing Allah
Allah listen my friend my brother Allah
is the best advisor in all of your
problems I repeat again the one true God
any problem that you have he can be the
track of all but he cannot specialize in
one no that's see what you've found is
attributed a human to God because
because a man can't do that you're
thinking about a man oh if I need this I
go to this specific if I need to get my
car done I go to a mechanic I need my
tie shop I go to the tie shop the tie
shop cannot be the mechanic the mechanic
cannot be the accountant the accountant
cannot be the solicitor we are talking
about the Creator you're talking about
the creation you're equating the
creation to the Creator my my brother
you've got a million problems there is
one true God that can deal with them in
the best way himself not do you
understand that this is why you're stuck
where should God alone I'm I'm inviting
you to Islam that's true creator I'm
telling you I've been a Muslim for 11
years all my problems I go to him he
solves them or he makes me patient and
gives me something better he solves them
I don't go to hundreds or different
that's I do that in the human being I
need to get a haircut I go to my hair
dress I don't go to my mechanic yeah
they are the creation you're equating
the creation to the Creator the Creator
is far greater than the creation do you
understand so what from accepting
think about it if someone created
Created like like a website okay let's
let's give this website Creator name
like suit or something and he had
different like administrators for the
website would you go straight to suit or
would you go to the different
administrators I would go straight look
the analogy you're given I will go to
the one look I will go to the one who is
the master of all of that I'm not going
to go to those who are like yeah I'm a
supervisor I'm a manager now i' I want
to go to the source and that is God
Almighty why do you want to go to these
people who are not experts and who are
false deities that cannot even benefit
you for example Allah says in the Quran
that if a fly was to come in front of
the idol Brahma whatever you vishna
whatever you want to call and the Fly
was to take its food it can't even
protect its food from the fly how are
you worshiping things that you have made
with your own hands you're you're a
transgender Hindu yeah you can be a
trans you can be look you can be I'm not
saying that you should but you can be a
trans trans Muslim you're a Muslim but
you're committing a sin okay I'm telling
you at least come and have worship of
Allah alone at least die on look we
accept you we accept you with your sin
we don't we don't say that it's a good
thing we accept you why don't you accept
Islam have one source that you go to
with all your problems man forget I'm
going to go to vishna sometimes you
might even get the names mixed up oh oh
supposed to be uh what was it crop crop
what was it called CS yeah I was
supposed to go to him oh no his name I
forgot but brother one name you need one
name that will solve all your problems
Allah all of your problems Allah just
one name you don't even need to if I was
that I would get confused man oh who's
vishna for I got confused I went to I
went to vishna for the wrong thing I was
supposed to go to the other one Allah
one God so I'm inviting you to Islam and
you know what I will teach you how to
pray I will give you you know this
prayer M yeah my dear brother we want
Islam for you look look you will we will
teach you how to pray you see here
brother look I will teach you how to
pray step by step yeah and imagine you
worshiping God alone when you pray
imagine you look let me tell you
something yeah something very profound
one sec I'm gonna go my charger real
quick but I'll I'll still okay no
problem just just listen to me yeah so
now imagine you're praying but you've
got five problems today Financial
somebody upset you you're going through
an illness now you're thinking oh I need
to write down I need to go to this God
for that that God for this do you
understand the beauty of going to Allah
and saying oh Allah I have all my
problems and I only have you to turn to
and you know you imagine how power Just
DE that bro you're going to one creator
for all your problems rather than going
to multiple creators with multiple
problems Hinduism is the oldest
continuingly
practice no no no no no no we Islam is
the oldest religion We Believe Islam
came from day one Islam didn't come 1400
years ago just so you know yeah Islam
came from Adam from day do yeah so what
we're saying is that Islam's message was
that God is one so what I'm saying is
this look in a nutshell like obviously
um I want to also help you ask your
question but we've got limited time like
I said before when you go to pray when
you go to pray you have if you have five
problems pertaining to different areas
of your life you're going to have to go
to Five demig Gods I if I have 20
problems I go to one God and I ask him
for the problems for all of them all of
them and he has the capabilities of
answering all of them so look Islam is
there it doesn't have hierarchy it's the
worship of one God and believe me you're
just thinking about the creation he
can't do this I will do that and listen
you know very well it is much better to
go to the king directly than go to his
sub this person that person to the
governor this that you know what that
means that King doesn't have time for
you if you had the opportunity you would
go to the king exactly who would you
want to go simple question the king
let's say the king of the world yeah
let's say there's a king an individual
and he has all these Governors and and
this Etc and you have to talk to them in
problems and what about if he says to
you what about the king says to you I am
open to listen to you yeah you you you
hear amongst all the people he wants to
listen to you and all those other people
well yes who would you he could listen
to me but he wouldn't be able to listen
to all the other people no but I'm
saying to you Allah has the capability
let me tell you something if every
single person on Earth was praying to
God he listens to every single one and
can answer every single one that is who
Allah is do you understand you do you
understand the belief we have about God
oh it's it's like you know you have
peace be upon him so when you say brah
so would you like reference one like the
ways he will always be a gem okay yeah
oh no no no no no no no no no anyway no
no no we can't say no we can't say that
we can't said it no I'm saying you did
I'm I'm just I'm just letting him know
that yeah we we we we can't say that
yeah uh so anyway so what we trying to
say is my brother is that you know what
you said about un how can God listen to
everything look in the definition it
says this the thing that
unifies the unity behind all
diversity that one point where
everything it's it's yes true and also
one thing I want add though is that
there's certain terminologies use that
that we don't believe in like
Consciousness and he's like he's all in
we don't believe this concept that Allah
is all in one ET think he's like a
general yeah yeah cuz you know what it
is their definition might be a little
bit different we don't believe in
Consciousness no Ali that's not what
saying not saying that yet so just I
just need to give that disclaimer
because again people I know what's going
to happen yeah so so guys so do does
that make sense brother in a nutshell
yeah um I'm calling you to worship one
God so is D just worshiping one God you
have many problems like I said before he
can hear all of them so the choice is
yours I invite you to Islam if you would
like to come uh it's the worship of one
true God you worship him alone um and
you can be you are a trans person you
said you can still be a Muslim you know
so yeah so would you it's up to you I'll
leave the ball in your court um okay I
think I'm going to say Hindu I'm going
to practice um so party okay um shouts
out Sam Tyler
um sorry say that again oh I said I
think I'll continue to be a Hindu for
now but okay that's fine to there's no
in Islam we believe there's no
compulsion in religion we have conveyed
the message to you and the rest is up to
you I call you to the worship of one God
but carry look we would like to hear
from you throughout Ramadan we here he
was a very lovely person polite asked
questions listened uh so yeah it was
really nice talking to you and please
join us at Ramadan thank you very much
okay bye take thank you really
appreciate really appreciate these kind
of call and you know what as he was
talking the donation were coming in we
are literally 210 away from our our
Target we amazing
donation the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam said whoever builds a Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah on that day where Allah subhana
tal tells us that our books will be
given and every little at and weight of
Good Deed you've done will be there and
imagine you see a mountain and you're
like what a lucky person which righteous
person and Allah says this is for you
for me yes what did I do you allowed
people to pray you built a Masjid I
never had the money to build a Masid
Allah you helped you gave towards it and
Allah gives you the reward of as if you
built it donate now guys and do not
delay and share the video for extra
[Music]
Rewards